[Musique]
je suis partie des jeux outils parce que
il m'était impossible d'y vivre
je me sentais menace et j'ai ma raison
même été surveillés par les services des
renseignements mais pas été surveillé je
pourrais me faire empoisonner dans une
cafétéria ou même me faire renverser par
une voiture
je pouvais plus trouver du travail donc
je pourrai plus avoir une fille temps
que ce gouvernement est en place
[Musique]
ouais
non
après avoir licencié il voulait coûte
que coûte que je reste sous leur
influence et que voilà j'ai soir là ne
rien faire et être perdus et regretté
dès mon militantisme et tout ce que je
fais
[Musique]
d'entièrement de catastrophes 21 ans
destruction de l'éducation nationale des
habitants ont manifesté pour dire non
cinquième mandat
des jeunes du quartier de à chiba et ils
ont été arrêtés
donc j'ai essayé de leur faire passer un
message de leur dire sais c'est pas une
arrestation qui doit vous arrêter
[Musique]
j'étais blessé par balles le 21 décembre
en pleine réunion de l'opposition y
décèle ma vie n'a pas été respecté nous
comptons plus on la voit sur les urnes
ni sur les moyens
comment dirais-je électorale car on sait
très bien avec ce régime là il a boudé
il à bâillonner l'opposition
djiboutienne
que le cas de l'europe sont considérés à
séquestrer des hommes mais aujourd'hui
qu'ils emmerdent une barbarie du régime
on peut comme des voleurs sans vous ce
qu'est qui disparaissent qui les prend
cc c'est inquiétant quoi cc on savait
avant c'était la police usd est d'accord
voilà des noms aujourd'hui non des
civils vous prendre une voiture vous bat
l'apprenez on peut prendre toute la
population sans l'opposition je pense
n'a pas du tout des leçons de morale
politique à donner à qui que ce soit et
je pense qu'aujourd'hui le simple fait
qu'elles avancent qu'elles boycottent
c'est tout simplement une expression de
sa part une certaine forme de faiblesse
parce qu'elle sait pertinemment qu'elle
n'arrivera certainement pas à convaincre
l'opinion nationale
il ne faut pas oublier que nous avons
deux personnes des citoyens qui pour
faciliter justement leur exil dans un
pays étranger pardon pas leur exil mais
en tout cas leur statut dans un pays
étranger ils partent avec des visas
étudiants ou pour des vacances et qu'ils
ne veulent plus du tour et venir c'est
leur choix
ce n'est pas à moi de les juger mais
pour faciliter justement leur
installation
bien évidemment il ya cette facilité dès
dire qu'ils sont dans l'opposition
nous
[Musique]
e
m